[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 5 mai voici les
titres près de 400 sportifs réunis au
vélodrome nationale ce jeudi un tournoi
international de parra tennis de table a
été lancée jusqu'à dimanche c'est la
deuxième édition de cet événement en
quelques mois à saint quentin en
yvelines cette actualité le reste des
informations du jour dans le département
au début de cette édition il ouvrira ses
portes en septembre prochain à maurepas
le nouveau centre aqualudique castagna
sera installé en lieu et place de
l'ancienne piscine de la ville le site
est à la recherche de ses salariés 10
postes à pourvoir un job dating se tient
mardi prochain sur place les détails à
suivre et puis la 18e édition de la nuit
européenne des musées se déroulera le 14
mai tv 78 prend de l avance pour vous
donner le programme dans les yvelines
est notamment au musée départemental
maurice denis qui proposera une
expérience sonore et participative on en
parle avec notre invité pierre marie
vautier le début de ce journal donc avec
l'essentiel des informations à retenir
de cette journée du lundi et du jeudi 5
mai dans les yvelines le détail et le
résumé avec mathilde franco dans
l'actualité de ce jeudi 5 mai des élus
du plateau de saclay ont envoyé une
lettre au premier ministre
ils craignent que la future ligne 18 du
métro grand paris qui devrait relier
versailles à orly menace les terres
agricoles un grand gala de charité au
profit de l'ukraine est organisée ce
dimanche 8 mai au château barthélemy
dans la ville de paris doha ville située
au sud des yvelines au programme un
concert de musique ainsi qu'un buffet
avec des plats traditionnels d'ukraine
les fonds récoltés seront reversés à des
as ciation pour envoyer du matériel
médical aux ukrainiens et de mardi à
mercredi la tension est montée entre des
policiers et des jeunes dans le quartier
du val-fourré à mantes-la-jolie
plusieurs incendies ont été déclarés
entre 1h et 4h du matin à l'origine
l'interpellation d'un homme de 19 ans
qui était activement recherché par la
police en prenant la fuite il s'est
réfugié à l'insu d'une famille qui fait
l aïd lors de l'intervention les agents
ont utilisé du gaz lacrymogène la scène
a été filmée et fait polémique la mairie
a mobilisé des médiateurs pour apaiser
la situation des agents forestiers
victimes d'agressions et d'actes
d'incivilité certains promeneurs en
colère à cause des opérations de coupe
d'arbres s'en prennent aux employés de
l'office national des forêts
dégradations de matériel menaces
insultes selon une enquête réalisée par
le nf en ile-de-france 91% des agents
déclare avoir été victime ou témoin
d'une altercation on termine avec un peu
de sport un tournoi international de
tennis de table handisport a débuté ce
jeudi 5 mai au vélodrome nationale
depuis le retour des jeux ils ont ils
ont coupé un petit peu et depuis janvier
on est un stage par mois pour le groupe
france donc à 18 sportifs à peu près et
donc là le dernier stage chez ya deux
semaines donc on a peaufiné les derniers
réglages pour venir ici qui est l'une
des étapes importantes pour la
qualification aux championnats du monde
qui seront à me rendre le tournoi se
poursuit jusqu'au 10 mai en présence de
380 points gist de l'élite
internationale et de plusieurs médailles
paralympiques d tokyo et nous
reviendrons plus longuement sur cet
événement au vélodrome nationale lors de
notre prochain c'est huit sports lundi
prochain sur tv 78 ça recrute près de
chez vous le centre aqualudique de
maurepas organise un job dating mardi 10
mai le site ouvre ses portes en
septembre prochain et doit composer son
équipe accueillent enseignements de la
natation entretien de l'équipement 10
postes en tout sont à pourvoir sur place
les détails de nicolas landry
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
il
[Musique]
rendez vous donc le 10 mai de 17h à 20h
à l'espace albert camus de maurepas ce
job dating est ouvert à tous et des
startups saint-quentinoise engagé pour
le climat c'est le cas d'une notamment
un cube et au ski cuba elle développe
une application pour réutiliser les
matériaux lors de la destruction d'un
bâtiment nicolas landry
[Musique]
je m'appelle marie pierre signalé je
suis responsable d'agencé bâtiment
durable chez cytale sita et c'est un peu
moins de soixante personnes qui tous les
jours cherche à réduire l'empreinte
environnementale du bâtiment
[Musique]
je suis dominique renard brazy j'ai
fondé à plier en 2019 à fria c'est une
une entreprise hébergés à skis cuba
l'incubateur de saint quentin en
yvelines et la mission daf les liasses
de simplifier le passage à l'économie
circulaire dans le bâtiment
[Musique]
la rencontre avec la fia c'est c'est un
réseau commun entre notre direction et
donc brazùk plus partenariat s'est fait
assez simplement par par la proximité
puisque btp consultant sita et btp
diagnostics sont situés à saint quentin
comme comme à fria on a eu un besoin qui
est de développer un outil pour une
facilité
pour nous faciliter la vie dans le
travail du quotidien dans la réalisation
de diagnostics bmd produits équipements
matériaux déchets
sita et et l'utilisateur de da kibo
l'assistant digitale du diagnostic le
diagnostiqueur va sur un sur un chantier
qui qui a pour but d' été construit en
partie ou en totalité
et va pouvoir quantifier
la matière sortante à thibault c'est un
outil digital qui permet de construire
facilement les scénarios de valorisation
des déchets sur des chantiers de
démolition et de déconstruction une fois
les données collectées il ya un travail
de compilation de données et d'analysé
de retranscription de cette donnée-là et
de définition d des potentiels de
valorisation pour chaque matière
l'intérêt pour nous et de plusieurs
ordres techniquement un apport de
compétences sur l'outil et concept de
mise en place d'un logiciel on est
vraiment dans l'innovation pour l'outil
digital à kibo on est dans l'innovation
dans la vitalisation du futur diagnostic
est là il est absolument nécessaire
d'avoir la proximité avec l'utilisateur
final puisque il faut que les
fonctionnalités répondent aux besoins
donc là on est vraiment dans le
développement agile le fait de passer
par une structure déportés qui est
focalisée sur sur le développement de
son outil
ça nous permet de
d'avancer plus rapidement l'utilisateur
réagi
à ce qu'on va lui proposer on a juste
c'est donnant-donnant dans le sens où
nous on va apporter de la ressource
humaine on va apporter de la data on va
apporter de
du principe utilisateurs et le besoin en
fait pour cet outil-là ce contact
vraiment très proches avec l'utilisateur
final permet d'être certain que les
fonctionnalités que l'on va proposer son
sont les bonnes donc ça ça permet
d'accélérer en fait les développements
il a justement du produit
[Musique]
les golden blog débarque dans les
yvelines la 8e édition fait étape ce
samedi à guyancourt ce dispositif lancé
par le double champion du monde
d'athlétisme ladji doucouré et vise à
rendre le sport plus accessible pour ce
battle de sprint une piste sera implanté
place du marché rue jean mallet et de
14h30 à 18h les explications du maire de
guyancourt interrogé par justine brasier
soudain forme très simple de battles ses
dires de 1 contre un sur des distances
de 50 mètres donc en sprint c'est ce qui
se passera notamment à guyancourt sur la
place du marché avec la rue jean mallet
qui va être temporairement une piste de
sprint de 50 mètres
d'amener l'athlétisme au sein des
quartiers qui habituellement se cantonne
plus tôt au stade et aux associations
c'est aussi de pouvoir faire rencontrer
des jeunes de quartiers différents dans
une aile huile
tu as été un personnage très forte du
sport français est un grand champion et
et il a décidé effectivement de créer
sap de par son parcours aussi puisqu'il
est lui-même issu de ces quartiers il a
découvert l'athlétisme par les
structures et il souhaite en faire
bénéficier effectivement des jeunes de
ces quartiers
il ya 28 dates en france du mois de mai
on est on fait partie des premières et
de la première de notamment sur saint
quentin en yvelines et des yvelines
d'ailleurs il ya vingt-huit d'actes
jusqu'au mois de septembre est en fait
il ne reste que le plus rapide de la
session en réalité sous la forme d'un
tournoi si vous voulez et à la fin il ya
une grande finale nationale au mois de
septembre
mais d'autres animations seront aussi
proposés à guyancourt cinq autres dates
seront à venir également à à saint
quentin en yvelines jusqu'au 10
septembre à la verrière trappe elancourt
les clayes sous bois et coignières notez
bien cette date le samedi 14 mai aura
lieu la 18e édition de la nuit
européenne des musées pour l'occasion
3000 établissements ouvriront leurs
portes le soir en europe dans les
yvelines les lieux culturels se prépare
aussi à accueillir le public et on
emporte avec mon invité pierre marie
vautier bonsoir bon ça vous êtes chargée
de médiation culturelle au musée
départemental maurice denis c'est à
saint germain en laye on va parler de ce
qu'a prévu le musée maurice denis c'est
une expérience sonore et participative
on en parle dans un instant autre
exemple d'abord dans ce journal avec un
petit tour d'horizon du côté de la ville
de jouy en josas avec mathilde de franco
[Musique]
la nuit des musées permet aux visiteurs
de découvrir ou redécouvrir leurs lieux
culturels préféré dans une ambiance
nocturne et dans les yvelines les idées
ne manquent pas pour cette 18e édition
de la nuit des musées nous avons choisi
deux
bédié une animation au jeune public sur
le parvis du musée jusqu'à l'entrée du
château de l'églantine les enfants vont
pouvoir réaliser à la craie des motifs
de toiles de juillet en s'inspirant de
motifs qui ont le camp leur proposera en
un autre médiatrice qui va animer les
ateliers à quelques pas de la maison
léon blum se prépare également à
accueillir le public
cette année donc nous avons
effectivement en partenariat avec le
conservatoire
donc vers 5 ans parc comme center de
musique donc nous avons monté donc un
projet effectivement pour que des élèves
donc sous l'égide sous la responsabilité
de leurs professeurs vêtements viennent
donc faire de l'animation musicale d'une
part dans le parc avec des cuivres et
puis dans la maison donc avec d'une part
un poteau donc la commande et paie
également eu des chants lyriques après
une période compliquée les lieux
culturels sont ravis de pouvoir
organiser et repartager des événements
avec le public
c'est plus qu'un jour c'est une
véritable respiration déjà pour l'équipe
du musée qui qui n'a pas cessé de
travailler en plein dans la période du
coc vide car amusé be à la même quand il
est fermé c'est une joie à plaisir que
que nous redécouvrons ou en quelque
sorte et nous étions effectivement de ne
pas dire de reconquérir parce qu'on n'a
jamais perdu deux publics sauf que c'est
celui-ci qui a été privée de cet échange
donc c'est un renouveau donc une
renaissance effectivement je dirais de
la culture à jouer d'autres animations
sont prévues dans les yvelines le palais
du roi de rome à rambouillet organise un
escape game le domaine royal de marly
fera une visite en musique et en danse
pour vous plonger au temps de louis xiv
et les plus jeunes pourront également
construire leur propre bateau au musée
de la batellerie à conflans
et on clôture à tout à l'heure le
journal avec d'autres idées dans les
yvelines mais direction à présent saint
germain en laye où je vous le disais le
musée maurice denis et musée
départemental proposera lui écouter au
musée c'est une expérience immersive
sonore et participative on en parle avec
pierre-marie vos tickets mon invité
chargée de médiation culturelle sur
place déjà on entendait dans le
reportage est il aussi une certaine
impatience pour vous d'accueillir le
public pour cet événement de la nuit des
musées alors oui pour nous c'est un
événement extrêmement attendu pour
n'importe quel musée avec les journées
du patrimoine ce sont vraiment les deux
dates annuelles qui sont repérés par
tous nos visiteurs donc oui oui puis
surtout que c'est un événement qui est
vraiment une réinvention à chaque fois
c'est ça c'est tout l'objectif on va
dire la nuit des musées c'est de
redécouvrir découvrir un musée d'une
autre façon
la nuit c'est un moment où on voit
différemment et du coup c'est une
occasion d'essayer de voir le musée sans
doute moins sous un regard
intellectuelle peut être moins sous le
regard des savoirs mais davantage avec
une approche émotionnelle une une
approche sensitive ou ou ludiques voilà
voir la nuit c'est voir autrement et des
coups c'est découvrir un musée autrement
donc vous pour avoir la nuit ce musée
maurice denis qui a rouvert il ya
quelques mois après trois ans de
fermeture pour les téléspectateurs qui
ne connaissent pas encore ce lieu
comment vous pourriez le présenter alors
alors ce musée c'est une petite bulle de
bien-être c'est un musée qui est déjà
dans un ancien hôpital du xviie siècle
donc c'est un bâtiment extrêmement beau
au milieu d'un jardin qui est tout aussi
beau et au milieu de cette petite bulle
de verre
verdure on trouve des essentiellement
des peintures mais également d'autres
arts décoratifs
qui sont en grande partie liés à maurice
denis qui a habité dans ce bâtiment et
aux peintres nabis donc ce sont des
peintres qui se situe entre le 19e
siècle et le 20e siècle on est juste
après les impressionnistes dans une
grande période qu'on appelle l'art
symboliste et ce sont des peintres qui
ont voulu remettre de l'âme remettre du
sensible dans la peinture et voilà c'est
vraiment un musée qui est tourné vers le
bien-être parce que voilà c'est une
peinture extrêmement douce extrêmement
belle extrêmement calme mais en pour
cette nuit des musées je le disais c'est
écouter musée une expérience sonore
immersive
participative qui est fait avec radio
sensations une radio locale implantée
dans les yvelines mais aussi dans
d'autres régions de france quel est le
principe concrètement alors c'est un
principe qui est expérimental je crois
qu'on n'a jamais essayé ailleurs les
visiteurs seront invités à déambuler
dans le musée normalement mais toutes
ces salles seront d'abord immergé dans
le dos de la musique de l'artiste aux
roses donc
c'est un jeune musicien qui sort sont
impropres première album il s'agit de
techno mélodique donc une techno douce
mais surtout il y aura un studio
d'enregistrement éphémère installé dans
la chapelle du musée et les visiteurs
s'ils le souhaitent pourront aller se
faire interviewer view view vais sur une
question qu'ils auront choisi à l'avancé
sur des questions extrêmement
personnelles sur leur rapport à l'art
sur les émotions qui ont été
suscités par le contact aux oeuvres à
l'exposition et des extraits de ses
interviews seront mixés en direct et
diffusé dans les salles d'exposition
question de telle manière à ce que
n'importe quel visiteur soit à la fois
plongé dans cette musique douce de rose
et en même temps soit interpellé par le
ressenti d'un autre visiteur de manière
à ce que sa visite soit enrichie par
l'expérience de visite d autres vies
vivi visiteurs voilà donc le participant
va en quelque sorte du coup pas
participer c'est le principe enrichir le
parcours de la vie c'est ce que vous
disiez avec notamment aussi vous parliez
de rose avec ce concert on peut
peut-être voir voilà le visage de rose
s'afficher un qui est un artiste qui
participera donc à cette soirée la
programmation a été construite autour de
lui donc ça c'est pour cette soirée de
la nuit des musées on retrouve plus de
détails le programme sur le site
internet juste des questions pratiques
pas besoin de réserver c'est c'est
gratuit bon déjà c'est une visite en
accès libre qui est gratuite qui est de
19 heures à 23 heures avec une
performance live de l'artiste aux roses
qui sera en 21h30 qui sera au milieu de
cette soirée qui se déroulera de 19h à
23h on va terminer sur les autres
enfants il y en aura d'autres puisque le
musée maurice denis va jouer en quelque
sorte des prolongations jusqu'au
jusqu'au mois de juin c'est ça oui oui
c'est tout nouveau l'exposition est
prolongée jusqu'au 19 juin et avant cela
on a deux grandes dates on a le 26 mai
qui sera une journée pour les
dessinateurs une journée croquis au
musée pour les peintres pour les ddd
dessinateur c'est gratuit pour ceux qui
dès qu'ils dessinent et enfin tout le
mois de juin sera consacrée au jardin
c'est la deuxième édition pour nous de
ce qu'on a baptisé joint au jardin avec
comme temps d'orgue une journée de
reconstitution historique le dimanche 19
juin avec la compagnie de l'histoire et
des harkis sont une compagnie de
bénévoles absolument passionné par le
costume historique et par la
reconstitution d art de vivre et du coup
on pourra déjeuner sur l'herbe comme
dans un tableau impressionniste de manet
de monnaie ou de cearà et je le disais
on retrouve bien sûr toutes les
informations sur le site internet du
musée départemental maurice denis et
donc cette date à retenir le 14 mai la
nuit des musées avec au musée maurice
denis écouter le musée qui est une
expérience immersive sonore et
participative réalisé avec radio
sensations merci à pierre marie vautier
d'être venu en parlant plateau je vous
remercie grâce à elle que vous êtes
chargée de médiation culturelle pour ce
musée là départemental maurice denis on
referme justement cette édition en
continuant de parler de cette nuit au
musée avec une sélection aussi réalisé
par matt hill de franck où regarder
[Musique]
comme vous 3
tél
[Musique]
à
quel moins
[Musique]
le pas
matin
voilà vous savez tout ou presque sur
cette nuit des musées 2022 dans les
yvelines c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de votre fidélité dans un instant
vous retrouverez une autre édition de ce
journal qui sera diffusée en replay je
voulais vous parler demain je vous donne
rendez-vous à demain plutôt avec
l'émission 7,8 week-end l'émission
satirique haine c'est une émission avec
de l'actualité des idées de sorties pour
bien terminer la semaine dans les
yvelines belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]